- On this episode,
Adam Braun stops by
to talk MissionU.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode
249 of The #AskGaryVee Show.
I am really pumped up,
because one of
my favorite humans
is here with me today.
Adam Braun, founder
of Pencils of Promise,
a non-profit that I am
very deeply involved with.
As a matter of fact,
this is super fun.
Don't give me a
pat on the shoulder.
I just took four shots today.
- Yeah, you're going!
- 'Cause I'm going to Ghana
in a couple weeks
to see some of the
schools that we've been
putting to work.
- Now, over a hundred in Ghana
- So excited.
- so I'm very
excited for you to see it.
- I want you to tell everybody
about your work in that world,
a little bit on that,
and then what
you're up to in a minute,
but I first wanna say
what's up to everybody.
Thanks so much for everybody
who's been watching the content.
The, what did we name it?
Fuck Them, Send 'Em to Me?
- [Andy] For All The Haters.
- Oh, you guys changed it?
These guys fucked it up,
but it should have been called,
Fuck Them, Send 'Em to Me.
Let's link that
up in this episode.
If you haven't
watched this video--
what did we get, five
million reach on that?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- Cool, so check that out,
but before we
talk Knicks and Jets,
and how the first time we met,
Mark Sanchez walked
into the restaurant.
- Yep, yep.
- Before we go into all that,
why don't you tell
the people that
are watching right now
what you're up to now,
and then we'll bounce back,
because what you're up to now
scratches an
itch that is very deep
in my soul.
- Yeah, so, right now,
I'm focused as a
co-founder and CEO of MissionU.
MissionU is a
college alternative
for the 21st century,
so we prepare
students for the jobs
of today and
tomorrow, debt-free.
We think, at our core,
that the current
college landscape
is fundamentally broken,
that students are leaving school
without the actual
skills needed to succeed
in their careers
and in the work force,
and even if
they do get a degree,
they're left with absolutely
crushing, crippling debt.
When I met my wife,
she had over
$100,000 of student debt
without getting
that bachelor's degree,
and, so, we are building a
one-year college alternative
for the 21st century.
You pay no
money at all up front.
We invest in
you for a full year,
and at the end of that year--
- Goose egg?
- Yeah, zero.
- Zero.
- Zero. Zero.
- Benoit Benjamin.
- Correct.
(laughs)
- Like, you pay zero.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Keep going.
I love that part.
- And then, once you complete
your year at MissionU--
- But it's hard
to get in, right?
- Yeah, I mean we've had--
- Like, you wouldn't take Jake.
Jake would apply,
and you'd be like,
"We're not gonna
make any return on him,
"so he's out."
- Well, here's one
thing that I think you,
in particular, would love.
We don't look at SAT.
We don't look at GPA,
and you don't have to
have a high school degree
to get into MissionU,
because none of those
things actually matter
or are clear indicators
of whether somebody's
gonna be a great contributor
to a great company, so,
when you get a well-paying job,
in making $50,000 or more,
you contribute
15% of your income
back to MissionU
for three years,
and that enables us to
extend that opportunity
onto the next student,
so we launched MissionU--
- You guys hear that?
- Officially--
- Like, think about
this business model.
It's completely aligned.
- [Eliot] I might apply!
- Yeah, I mean, you might--
you shouldn't,
because you're crushing it--
- So, I mean we're basically--
- But like I mean, I--
or maybe you should.
Like, it's really
interesting, right?
So basically, people apply.
It's a one-year thing.
- Yep.
- But you're
contractually obligated
to give 15% of your salary
once you make over 50K.
- Correct, but only if
you actually get there.
- Right, so are
people gonna be crafty,
and ask for like 49?
(laughs)
- I think there are
some people that are probably,
especially in like the
- They'll probably look
at mine or something,
- start-up world,
they're gonna look for 49.
- "Maybe 49!" (laughs)
- The thing is you have
an opportunity to defer,
and, so, let's say that
you complete the program,
and then you don't get a job
that pays you $50,000 or more.
That's used as
part of your deferment.
- And does the model work--
so as you can imagine,
being on the board
of Pencils of Promise
for the last four years or so,
I've gotten to
know Adam super well,
so he goes, "Hey, I'm
going into for-profit."
Part of my life.
We spent a lot of
time jamming about that,
so I was very close to it,
and then he's
like, "I got an idea!
"I got an idea!"
I think I was in a cab,
and it was raining,
and you were
like, "Here's the idea!"
I'm like, "I'm in!"
- Yeah.
- "I'm investing in this."
- You were literally
the first person I told
about it.
- I, and, so,
I love this thesis.
A lot of you who watch my stuff
know why I love this thesis.
Let me ask you a question
of something I don't know,
'cause I was so blindly in,
I didn't look at
every t and every i.
If Tyler did it,
he makes 42K in his first job,
but he gets
promoted and makes 63,
does he then go on the clock?
- Yeah.
- Got it.
So that's how it works.
- Yep.
Yep.
- So basically,
Don't collect debt.
We're gonna teach
you the right skills.
You signed up a
bunch of companies
that are hiring
the people outta this.
- Yeah, so our
employer-partners commit
to three things.
The first is they
advise us on the curriculum,
so that we're
actually teaching you
the skills and, you know,
software and tools
and whatever else that
companies are
actually interested in
that are leaders of industry,
and, so, the whole
industry tends to be
interested in those spaces.
The second is they
help us develop things
like case studies or, you know,
chime in and do Skype chats,
and you get
exposure to great leaders
of great companies,
and then the third
part is we give them
early preferred
access to hire our top grads.
So, you know, very
few companies in the world
are gonna guarantee spots.
You have to earn your own way,
but you're
gonna have an on-ramp,
you know, just as
strong, if not stronger,
than if you had a
traditional bachelor degree,
and right now, our
employer-partners are
companies like Spotify,
Lyft, Uber, Warby Parker,
Casper, Harry's,
Bonobos, Birchbox, VaynerMedia,
a handful of others,
so, you know, some of the
best companies in the world
that almost
every person I speak to
would do anything to work at.
These are the exact companies
that are helping us
design an experience
that is a perfect on-ramp
for the talent that
they're looking for.
- So when's the first class?
- So, we opened up admissions
exactly about a month ago.
- How's it going?
- So, we have 25 spots
for our September cohort.
We've had just about
3,000 applicants so far
for the first 25
spots in the first month.
- So that's gonna be, like,
a lot of disappointed people.
- Well what
we're now thinking is that
we need to launch more
cohorts and more quickly,
so we're targeting
- But I know you well enough
and I've watched you
- other cohorts in January.
- build other things.
You're gonna do it--
you're not
gonna go crazy, right?
You're, like, you're
gonna be smart about this.
- No, I mean, if we
stopped our admission process
right now, today,
which we're not doing,
we would still have less
than a 1% acceptance rate,
and that would
make us more selective
than Harvard and
Stanford combined,
so, we're gonna be
a selective institution,
but we don't look at the things
that traditional
academia usually values.
What we look for in
our admissions process
is character traits,
like, you know,
ambition, resilience, grit.
Are you self-directed?
Are you a motivated learner?
And then the soft skills, like,
do you work well in teams?
Do you communicate
ideas effectively?
So it's totally different.
- Now, you've built
an onboarding process
that gives you insight to that.
Are you guys also then
interviewing people after?
Like, what's your process?
- So --
- How are you gonna get
to this 25?
- Yeah, so--
- I'm not gonna get a weird text
that says, "Can you
talk to Sally on the phone?"
- (laughs) No, no,
don't worry about it.
- Thank God.
- I will ask you--
- I wasn't sure
what I signed up for.
- I will ask you
to actually
address the students though
once they're fully accepted.
- Yeah, duh.
I'm gonna give the first
13 commencement speeches.
- Yeah!
So Gary's in as our
commencement speaker
for the next 13 classes.
You heard it here first.
- (laughs)
- Four-step admissions process.
First step's called
Tell Us About Yourself,
so, you know, just
share who and what you are,
your background, you know,
what your kind
of aspirations are.
Second step is an
admissions challenge.
It's open book, so
you can use the internet.
We actually
encourage you to use Google.
It's untimed.
You can use any thing
except for another human,
'cause that's how the
working world actually works.
It makes no sense that
you take a test in a vacuum.
And then,
those who do well there,
they advance to
a group challenge.
The group challenge is probably
the most interesting part.
You enter a live
virtual classroom.
You get a prompt,
so one that we're using is like,
"Self-driving vehicles
are coming to our society.
"Will they have a
positive or a negative impact
"on our culture, and why?"
And you spend 35
minutes, as a group,
creating a
presentation that you give
for the last ten
minutes to one of our staff,
and we record the whole thing,
and we go back and
we watch that tape,
and then the final
step is a personal interview
with myself or another
member of the leadership team.
- I love it man.
- Yeah.
- Enjoying it?
- I'm loving it right now.
It's so interesting.
- How long were you running
Pencils of Promise?
- So I founded
Pencils of Promise October 2008,
and then, you know,
I was on board until,
in an active capacity,
until the very end of 2015,
so probably seven years,
and now I'm obviously
Founder and Board Emeritus.
I was actually almost
gonna stop by the office today,
and then I got
pulled away for a second,
but, I mean, I'm probably on
a Pencils of Promise email,
I would say, every single day,
but it's nice that
we have a great CEO
that's leading the
organization day to day.
- And how does it feel to, like,
be in the startup world?
You're living in San Francisco.
- Yeah!
- So you're in that bubble.
- Yeah.
- Has it been an
interesting transition?
You know, what I'm
fascinated by you is
you're the future of
philanthropy, in my opinion,
which is I grew up in a mindset,
and until I met you and
Scott Harrison and some others,
of like "Oh, I'll do my thing,
"and then when I'm old,
"then I'll start giving away
"and giving back."
I've changed that
mindset, obviously,
but even founders
were never as young as you.
You know, usually, it
was a different profile.
Wasn't a type A winner of
starting these kinda things.
- Yeah.
- So I've been very fascinated
about you re-entering the world
as a young man
off a decade of that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- How's it been?
- I mean, it's
probably one of the
most rollercoaster-ish
periods of my life,
partially because also,
Gary knows this very well,
but my wife gave birth
to twins five months ago.
Literally today,
they're five months old.
And so, I have like three things
that just entered my life
that I'm trying
to give my all to.
But, I couldn't be
more grateful or happy.
First all, I found something
much like Pencils of Promise
that lived at the
intersection of where,
I feel like my
personal purpose exists.
As well as, it gives
me the opportunity to
create a living that
I can support my family
and the things and
causes that I believe in most.
It's also, like I'm not a first
time entrepreneur anymore.
And you know, for
Pencils of Promise,
you were in those
board meetings with me.
I mean, they weren't always easy
but managing a 12
person board for years,
by the time I had replaced
myself with Pencils of Promise,
we had over a hundred
full-time staff in 5 countries,
we've founded
more than 400 schools,
raised well over
$40 million dollars.
So, it's fun to go
back to the building stage.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- That's what I missed.
I missed the
ability to take an idea
when you see
something wrong with the world
and you have a
different kind of vision for
where it could go that
nobody else necessarily sees.
Telling someone two years ago,
that I wanted to
build a college alternative
for the 21st century was like,
outside of you,
and a couple
other of our friends,
it was crazy.
- I was like,
"Yes, I'm committed."
- I think five years from now,
we're gonna look
back and be like,
"Of course."
College is so ridiculously
over-priced, it's not succeeding
for the students
that are looking to--
- But that's the
world we live in, right?
Like, hey, wouldn't
it be cool if you could
press a button on
your iPhone and a black car
would pick you up, you're
gonna jump into people's cars.
Telling people ten years
ago, you're going to go into
stranger's cars.
Like, parents of high
school kids are forcing kids,
of wealth, to have Uber
accounts instead of driving
because they don't
want them drunk driving.
So they're telling
their 15-year-old daughter
to get into a stranger's car.
- Yeah.
- Like, think about me
saying that ten years ago.
- Yeah, I mean,
it just didn't exist.
I would say, overall,
the difference between
New York and
San Francisco is massive.
- Yes.
New York's much better.
- I would agree.
As a city, San Francisco
doesn't hold a candle.
- San Francisco, you suck!
- That said, if you
lived just outside of the city,
- You still suck, no.
- SF is unbelievable.
It is unbelievable just outside.
- Real quick, I apologize.
Facebook, start
putting your phone numbers in
if you wanna talk about
startup culture, philanthropy,
clearly college or
alternatives, startup.
You wanna talk to me,
wanna talk about The Jets,
Jets and Knicks,
we can do that.
So any
competition, the Brauns and
Vaynerchuks
definitely share that.
So anything you wanna talk
about putting your numbers in.
Andy, you've got numbers?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- Let's get the first one going.
What else, while we get
the first question going,
what else do you want the
masses to know about MissionU?
Raising twins.
What else you got to say?
- I think one think that's
kind of interesting about us
is where we're focused.
Right now, we have one major.
The front half of the
area is what we call foundation
and discovery, combination
of hard and soft skills.
The back half of the
area is on your major.
And right now, the
major that we're focusing
on is data analytics,
which is like this
exploding industry.
So boot camps tend to focus on
coding and software engineering.
That's not our focus,
we're on data analytics.
And these are
really well paying jobs.
You don't have to
have a college degree.
- Nick, hold on.
Adam's still talking.
I'm kidding.
Nick, it's GaryVee, you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with Adam Braun.
How are you?
- [Nick] I'm doing fantastic.
How are you, guys?
- Super well.
What's your question?
- [Nick] My question,
the one I stuck with was,
so in terms of,
you know, either of the things
I know of the
combo of the two things
that I know you two
are both really known for,
taking attention,
giving social media
the kind of slang term
of where we all live nowadays,
how would you guys utilize that?
What are your
thoughts on utilizing that for
creating
educational experiences?
You know, basically, using
those platforms to teach people.
If that makes any sense,
creating learning environment.
- So is the question like,
how would we think about
creating curriculum
on top of social
in a way of like
whatever Khan Academy
or all these other
platforms have done, collective,
things of that nature.
What's our opinion on layering
that on top of social itself?
- [Nick] That's like
exactly what I'm saying.
Do you guys have
any thoughts on that?
- No, I got you.
- [Nick] A more
specific question.
- I think the thing
that excites me most is
the opportunity that
every single individual
can both be a
teacher and a student.
Historically, you almost
had to have some type of
rote qualification, right?
You had to kind of
get a Phd in order to
be the sage on the stage.
And I think what Gary
has demonstrated, probably
better than
anybody else in the world,
is that you can use
social in building an audience
though education.
You know, your content, for
some people, is voyeuristic.
Like they just
love to watch your life.
But I think the main reason that
people love to watch
your life is they feel
that they're learning something.
And they're taking that and
applying it to their own journey
and I think
that many many people
are going to benefit
from that in the future
as more and more platforms,
not only that enable the
social layer, but focus on
specific niche areas
with in education emerge.
- [Gary] Here's what
I would say to this.
I would say that the internet
is the middle-man, right?
What we're seeing,
what we're living through
with Amazon and OTT
and Netflix and Uber
and on and on and on, Airbnb.
The internet is
the infrastructure.
And I think people are
struggling to understand that.
Back to your point in
using terminology, I believe
when the five to seven social
networks or content hubs,
because you know, people call
YouTube a social network now
even though it's not, per se.
That's the layer on top of
the internet that's current.
So I would say
that your intuition
or what you might be
thinking about is a startup
or where's the opportunity.
Of course.
I mean, it's the communication
hub of our society.
In essence,
blog posts, video content,
these are seminars,
or books, or passages.
So I think there are
a lot of opportunity.
I would say the one thing that
people have to keep in mind
is when you're building
on top of something else,
you're vulnerable
to that something else.
So if you're building on top
of Facebook or Instagram,
you have to figure
out how to get as much
value out if it
than it gets out of you.
I was with a
media mogul just now,
and he was like,
he was smart, he's young.
He was smart.
He realizes he has
to get the value out of
Facebook and Instagram
that it gets out of him.
And so, I would say,
if you can figure out
how to get the value out of it,
then you're fine.
For example, look at my content.
If I wanted to charge,
I get 50 emails a day like,
"Gary, you need to charge $4.99
"for DailyVee a week,"
or whatever.
"I'll pay 10 bucks."
You know, people
say this all the time.
If I wanted to charge,
I wouldn't be
as comfortable building on
top of Facebook and Instagram
because there's no
infrastructure for that, right?
I don't want to pay the
huge toll booth to Apple
that is, you know,
30 cents on the dollar either.
So I would go direct, but
I think what you need to do
is figure out how
to get value out of it.
And I think anybody
who's starting out early,
in the beginning
you get much more value
because you're
building way under the awareness
and attention and then if
you're looking to monetize,
then you can
start moving it off.
- Yep. I agree.
- Cool, thanks bro.
- [Nick] Hey, thanks-
(beeping)
- So, when you
were finishing a thought
when we did the call,
so data analytics is the place
you decided to attack first.
- Yeah, I mean we spoke to
literally dozens and
dozens and dozens of companies,
hundreds of people that are
on the front lines of hiring,
and this space
of data analytics,
an article just came out.
Somebody sent me, I think it
was maybe last week,
with an interview with
Eric Schmidt at Google,
and the headline is,
"This Is The Most Important
Skill of the 21st Century."
and it's basically taking data
and being able to
use that to tell a story
to make a business decision.
And it lives in every
function of a business.
And we have a
huge shortage predicted
in the years ahead so
that's where we start.
- My entire career has
been predicated on my intuition
and then working backwards,
but what's far
more scalable is to
actually look at
the data and make those.
And people who can analyze
the data makes a lot of sense.
So is it the concept?
Are you guys going to
continue to create majors
that you think map to
underserviced by the market?
- Yeah, and now
what I'm interested in
is like in the health space,
nursing for example.
I mean, the amount of open
jobs in nursing is massive.
- Hey, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
You're on The #AskGaryVee Show
with Adam Braun.
How are you?
- [Janet] I'm doing good.
How are you all?
- We're doing super well.
What's your name?
- [Janet] I'm Janet Adams.
- Hey, Janet.
- [Janet] And my question for
him, as someone who speaks
on college
campuses around the country,
trying to help students
get out of student loan debt,
his story about his new,
I think it's MissionU--
- Yep.
- [Janet] caught my eye
over the last
week and definitely,
I know that it's just
for a check currently,
but how are you gonna be able
to shift it in the future
to maybe cover other
majors that are available
and would it work
with Corporate America?
- Yeah, um.
- [Gary] It's
awesome that you said nursing
right before she,--
- I mean it's
a great question.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- We're literally just
kinda diving into this.
I mean, our goal is, again,
to build a college alternative
for the 21st century.
That means multiple majors
serving multiple
different areas.
The most popular
undergraduate major
in the country
right now is business,
but I'm sure many
of us have met people
who graduated
with a business degree
and still have no
clue about how to actually
contribute to a company.
And so that's
why our first focus
is on data analytics
and business intelligence,
but as I was just
saying to Gary, you know,
a real area of personal
interest for me is nursing.
We have
literally millions of jobs
that are about
to become available
as we have an aging
Baby Boomer population.
The current population of
nurses are heavily retiring.
There's a lot of different
jobs that are gonna emerge
within just the
health space in general,
that I don't think
traditional education
is gonna prepare people for.
And then when it
comes to actually
the Corporate America
side, this is already happening
whether MissionU existed or not.
So PricewaterhouseCooper,
Ernst &amp; Young,
two of the biggest
accounting firms in the country,
in the last 18
months have removed
the bachelor degree requirement
in order to get a
job at their company.
Obviously, Google has
done it in the tech space,
but you look at like
industries as old as publishing,
Penguin Books, one of
the largest publishers,
also removed
the bachelor degree.
So I think we're gonna
see a really large movement,
especially as Millennials, in
the next five to eight years,
become the dominant hiring
component of our workforce
because so many, you
know, I'm a Millennial,
I'm at the top end,
but so many of us recognize
that whether
somebody got a degree or not
is actually not
all that important.
It's much more about, you know,
where they got into school
is a helpful sorting mechanism,
but it's only one data point.
How they present in the room,
what their references are,
what their previous
work experience,
things like internship,
all of that, I think is
gonna increasingly matter
much, much more
than their transcript
or their major or their
GPA 'cause I can tell you,
you know, in my entire career
I don't think I've ever looked
at somebody's
transcript, not once.
- [Janet] And that's why
I try to tell the student
I am my own company,
Debt Sucks University.
(Adam laughs) And
like even Gary has truly
helped me talk to the
students into different ways
to make sure that they're ready,
and I've started
him on to so many people,
but I just wanna turn
on the higher ed community,
then you, because
it's just interruption,
just like we talking
about with Uber and so forth,
and I just think higher
ed needs to really get ready
before Uber does the
same way they did to taxis.
- I think you're exact,
I mean look,
they are so
stunningly vulnerable
because they think
what Adam said is so right.
People are like oh
Millennials are coming
and this has already happened.
You have people in their
early 30s that are achieving
and becoming
leaders of our world
who look at the world
completely differently
and they're gonna be
the judge and the jury,
and so Samantha, 32 years old,
who knows that her
emotional intell, I mean
I didn't think Adam
was gonna be that great
'cause he did go to
Brown instead of the reverse.
Like I actually
pre-judge people in reverse
and that's gonna
become far more common.
And to your question,
the corporations,
you know, when you look at
if you're a
15-year-old right now
and you think about it's
three, seven years from now,
when you
understand first of all,
the corporations of
seven years from now
look a lot more like
Warby Parker and Casper,
whether those
companies win or not
after there's an
economic downside, I don't know.
That model is
definitely gonna win.
So, and what I mean by that
model, I mean newer businesses
that are gonna be worth four,
ten, 15, $100 billion,
like, they're coming.
And their DNA is so different
and they're gonna
be the decision makers,
and so I think you're
barking up the right tree.
I'm glad that it's
caught your attention
and you know, what
I'm most excited about,
I would tell
you besides the fact
that I genuinely
love this human being,
I'm just excited about the
legacy of being involved in it
because I know
there's gonna be more things
that look like it.
- Oh yeah.
- I know you're gonna
build the biggest one.
At least, it's
very important to me
that you accomplish that.
- Me too, me too.
- But, I think this is coming.
This is coming.
So, thanks for the call.
- And thank you for the work
you do as well.
- [Janet] Thank you so much.
It's something that I love.
I'm actually speaking
on a campus tonight
and I'm gonna go in
there and show them the threat
that are against them and
how if they want to learn--
- So if you can go to MissionU,
just the letter U.com
and there's a
video on the homepage.
Just play 'em that video.
I think it'll accomplish
what you're seeking.
- And tell them
to become Jets fans.
- Yeah that's key.
- That's important to us.
- [Janet] I'll tell them
just become GaryVee fans.
(Adam laughs)
- Well, I'll take
the Jets even more so.
Anyway, thank you, take care.
Very sweet, alright
let's keep it going.
So look I mean this
is really out there, huh?
- Oh yeah.
- Like when you went out there
and you've been
doing a bunch of podcasts
and getting some awareness
and obviously and all that,
have you been overwhelmed?
Have you been underwhelmed?
Has it come from
a different angle?
What's been the biggest
surprise of the reaction?
- Yeah, I think the
biggest surprise for me
is the last eight years
focusing on Pencils of Promise,
people were curious,
that was the reaction.
Like I'd explain
I started this organization,
we're building schools
around the developing world.
People were like oh
how do you train teachers?
Or how do you
pick your communities?
There was curiosity.
When I talk to people about
the state of higher education
in this country,
there is a visceral reaction
and everybody
knows that it's broken.
- It's coming.
- And everybody knows somebody's
going to be hurt by it
and so people are psyched.
- Kyle, it's Gary Vaynerchuk
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show
with Adam Braun. How are you?
- [Kyle] Dude, holy shit,
I'm amazing. How are you?
- I'm doing amazing.
Where are you from?
- [Kyle] Dallas, Texas.
- I love it my man.
What's your question?
- [Kyle] Alright man,
my question is
how do you go about
learning how to delegate?
I've gotten to the point now
with my business that I'm
needing help and I end
as doing everything myself.
And I end up as
paying people basically just
to watch me do the
work that I want them to do.
- What do you do?
- [Kyle] I'm in real estate.
- And what do
you want them to do?
Like, run open houses or
cold call or what are they
supposed to be
doing that you're doing?
- [Kyle] I mean really,
a little bit of everything.
The main thing that I do
is advertising and branding
for myself, so for them
it's more of just taking care
of leads, locking
down leads, getting things
scheduled on the calendar.
- Got it, so you're the top
of the funnel and you want
them to see it
through underneath you.
- [Kyle] Yes sir.
- Got it, and who
have you been hiring?
- [Kyle] I mean honestly,
I think this might be
my hitch up in going
for people that I just know.
- Which I'm not against...
You know, listen, I'll
be honest with you Kyle.
Honestly, I'm big fan
of that, believe it or not,
especially in your early days.
- I mean, that's your M.O.
- That's my M.O.
- I feel like I
hang out with Gary's crew
and it's like all his buddies--
- Yeah, I knew
his kids, I'm a big...
- [Kyle] That's
what I was trying to do.
I was trying to
give the same opportunity
that's been given
to me, to my boys.
- Here's the one thing though.
I didn't hire a single
one of my college friends.
- I don't hire
friends personally.
- But you had
Michael White, you...
- I get people
involved but it's...
I think at this stage
in my life I certainly can.
When I was in my,
call it, early to mid 20s
and I was building
something, it was hard for me
as leader to demand the
level of excellence that
I wanted without it kind
of hurting the relationship.
And so I just
stayed away from it.
Now I would probably
not have as big of an issue.
- Kyle, let me tell
you what the biggest thing
you need to figure out is.
- [Kyle] Okay.
- Whether it's your
friends or people like you,
you have to hire
people that are obsessed with
logistics and are
type A personalities.
- Mhmmm.
You have to hire that love
the shit that you and I hate.
- [Kyle] I feel you on that.
- You need to find
somebody who just loves Excel
and loves being
in their calendar.
And freaks out when
you're a minute late.
You need cross-your-ts
and dot-your-is.
I'm sitting with Adam
and asking him about details
of MissionU right now, with
you, because I don't do that.
You need to hire
people that do do that
because you're just
hiring homies or people that
look the part of you but
that's not what you need.
If you're the
quarterback you need to hire
offensive linemen,
they look different.
- [Kyle] Okay.
- Yeah.
The other thing I would say is,
the start of my career
I was probably much
the way that you were.
I was the person who
needed to do everything
myself because I
believed I could do
it better than
anyone on my team.
Then I spent three years
at Bain, which is arguably
the top culture in the
world for a corporate company.
What I saw there was,
that they spend an insane
amount of time
training people below them
to do the job that
they're doing today
so they can focus on
the next higher level issue.
So my biggest piece of
advice to you is, you should
look at how you're
spending your time and it might
feel really strange and
really awkward but you should
actually delegate, let's
say in the next two weeks...
- All, all...
- Call it 50%...
- Maybe all, of your time--
- All, it's two weeks.
- Teaching the people
that you are delegating to
to do all of your
exact responsibilities.
Literally to the
point where they can do it
as well if not
better than you can.
And then it will
free up your time.
Because at the end of the day,
delegation is a matter of trust.
And right now you're
not trusting these people
and that's because you
haven't invested in them.
- Or because they're losers.
- [Kyle] How do you go about
showing someone the vision?
You know, for me it's easy to
see because it's my vision.
How do you go
about showing someone...
- You don't, you
get rid of people
that don't buy into your vision.
If these are your
boys and they don't see
your vision, that
should be real fast.
- [Kyle] Okay.
- It's binary, brother.
Either they're bought
in that you're going to be
the biggest fucking
real estate mogul in fucking
Texas, America, the world,
the universe, or they don't.
And if they're just
there to collect a paycheck and
it's kind of easy because you
don't make them work hard.
You've got a problem and you
need to cut that cancer out.
- [Kyle] Okay, fuck yeah.
- I mean, that's it man, right?
I don't try to convince
anybody about my vision.
I'll give you my
fucking vision one time and
if you're not
bought in, fuck you.
- [Kyle] Nah yeah, fuck yeah.
I appreciate that, I really do.
- Yeah, and let me
tell you another thing...
- [Kyle] On how you look at it.
- But that's how
you look but that's
not how you're acting on it.
- [Kyle] Okay.
- You notice, if you've
been watching my content,
you know how I say
I never try to sell anybody,
like I'll try to
sell you one time but
if you're not in, you're out.
Like, it's fine, by the way,
I have hundreds of
employees at VaynerMedia
that are not fully bought in.
You need them, it's fine,
but I don't dwell on it.
I'm not emotional about it.
Like it doesn't
mean anything to me.
I'm on my mission and
so you need to just...
If they're literally
your homies or acquaintances,
the reason I built
companies with friends and
family is 'cause they are
automatically bought in usually.
If they're not, man, they're
just taking advantage of you,
slash, you need to
check your ego at the door.
You're right, it's about trust.
I love the fact that I know
every single person here
either is doing a
job that I can't do.
But if they're doing
my job, right like...
So the PR team,
the new business team,
Andy's job, those
are shitty jobs because
those are
things that I could do.
But I know if they're
doing it as an 8.3 to my 10,
or a 6.7 to my 10,
I can't do everything.
- And I'll tell you, the
greatest feeling in the world is
when you have a team
around you that takes
all those responsibilities
off your plate and
allows you to focus on
the thing that you can do
exceptionally well,
that they can't.
But right now you're
trying to do too many things.
- [Kyle] That's what I want,
I want the team, man.
I've been doing
everything on my own for
like five or six years.
- Then you're not
surrounded by the right people.
- [Kyle] That's what
I've been thinking...
- Or, or, or, or, or...
Let's do some basic math.
Let's say there's
four things you do and
you think you do
'em better than anybody.
Let's award you 10
full points, right,
you're getting 40 points.
Problem is there's 87
things that need to be done.
Do this math, if everybody
else is doing a two or
three but you're
getting all 87 things done.
The net score's greater.
People are crippled
by perfection
or doing everything right.
I think the thing
that I've always done
really well is you
just keep moving forward.
Just keep moving, nothing's
every going to be perfect.
So it's one of
two things, either
your homies suck
shit or you suck shit and
you like the ego boost
that you're better at it than
your average,
below average friends,
which means
you'll never be that big.
You've got to
figure out which one it is.
And it's probably
a little bit of both.
You know what I mean?
It always is
a little bit of both.
- [Kyle] I would agree,
for sure.
- That's it, man.
- [Kyle] I
would definitely agree.
So just increase my action,
and bring more people involved,
and just let it happen?
- And figure out,
are you holding it back
because it makes you feel good
that you're a
better salesperson,
the amount of people I watch
that build one and two
million dollar businesses
'cause they get
off on being the best
at all these little things,
it happens every day,
and I'm always like,
okay, that player's
gonna be an average player,
'cause they don't realize,
notice how I always talk about
sucking shit and everything?
And I suck at this,
- [Kyle] Yep.
- Like, you have to take
pride in your shortcomings,
because then you
start acknowledging them
and then, you know,
everybody's fronting
that they're so
awesome and everything.
I suck at
almost everything, yet,
I'm winning because
I surround myself with people
that know what
they're doing in that world.
I can't edit videos
like these characters.
- Mhmmm.
- [Kyle] Well, I think
that the problem I have
is that I see what,
I personally feel like
I see the potential in
the people that I bring on,
and I just can't get
them to actually see it,
or at least,
tap into it on themselves.
- Yeah, but if
you see it and they're
not bringing it to fruition in
a very short period of time,
then those
aren't the right people
that would be good at business.
- Yeah, you might also suck
at motivating people, bro.
- [Kyle] Okay.
- Like, that's a real part,
like me,
- Oh, yeah.
- We have to
understand these variables.
This is for everybody, right,
Kyle, I have no idea.
Like, it could
literally be that they're,
they're milking you and
they don't wanna do anything,
and you're the homie that's
kinda dragging everybody up,
that could be the case,
but I would also say,
maybe your management
style and leadership style
is making them go in reverse,
because maybe when
you should be using honey,
you're using vinegar, and when
you should be using vinegar,
you're using honey, it
could be an indication on you.
- [Kyle] Okay.
And I don't know, right?
- [Kyle] I definitely know,
I know that I suck at,
like I want to work with people,
I don't want
people to work for me.
- Okay.
- [Kyle] And, and that's a
big thing for me personally,
and I think
that at the same time
I'm too at fault with that,
because I don't want
to be someone's boss,
I want to, you know,
I just want to be,
does that make sense?
- Hell yeah it does.
- Yeah.
- Hell it does. Big time.
- Yeah, I mean,
- [Kyle] But I think,--
- That's where you kinda,--
- [Kyle] They almost want a boss.
Without knowing it.
- Dude, everybody wants a boss
that they go work somewhere.
- Yeah.
- If you go work somewhere,
you're looking for a leader.
- Yeah.
I would say you need
to step into that roll,
and not try to be
every person's friend,
in fact, there's
also a big difference
between a boss and a leader.
People are looking for a leader.
- [Kyle] Mhmmm.
- That's what
they need you to be.
Not the boss, they need
you to be a leader.
- [Kyle] That's what
I want to be.
- How old are you?
- [Kyle] I truly do. I'm 22.
- Good, man. You're a baby.
You're like, like, you're
a real fuckin' baby, right?
So, like you've got plenty
of time to mold into this.
The fact that
you're aware about this,
the fact that
you're watching this,
we're talking about this,
and you got time man.
I wouldn't cripple yourself.
You are literally a child.
Like, you're 22 years old.
You got a lot of time.
Listen, at 22, I was not able
to give critical feedback,--
- Right.
- to my employees.
I wasn't good at it.
- Hearing that you're
22 changes the equation.
I mean, I was 24 when
I started Pencils of Promise,
it was my friends
that were around me,
helping me throw
these parties, raise money,
and I could never
order them around,
and, you know,
I just didn't have the,
call it self-confidence,
as the, you know,
leader of the organization,
I was always grateful,
all those things,
but at the end of the day,
it becomes very clear
where the talent rises,
and the cream really
does rise to the top,
once you set a clear vision,
and then you
start holding people
accountable to real results, so.
- And you might have some,
- I wish you luck, man.
- I mean, Adam had
snobby friends like Brad H.,
you know, who could
never take feedback. (laughs)
So you gotta be careful with
who you surround yourself with.
Brad, I love you.
Kyle, good luck. Be patient.
- [Kyle] Alright, man,
I appreciate it.
- Here's what I would say,
let me give you one
real tangible thing.
Go have your first
ever negative conversation
with one of your employees,
just go taste it.
Just go in there,
- [Kyle] Okay.
- Sit down Rick, and be
like, Rick, listen to me.
We've been friends since
Little League and 4th grade,
I love you, you're the best,
you saved me from drowning
in the river in 9th grade,
but here's the
problem, you suck,
so either you get
your shit together,
or I have to fire you.
- [Kyle] Alright man.
Hey, I really
appreciate you taking the call--
- Kyle.
- [Kyle] giving me
all the advice,
- Don't jump off real quick.
You gotta promise to me that
you're gonna go
have that conversation.
- [Kyle] No, I literally am,
I gotta meet with a
couple of my guys tonight,
so we're gonna have a talk.
- Like, really,
now when you said
a couple of your guys,
if you're gonna
have that conversation,
make sure you have it
one-on-one.
- Yep.
- Don't start
lumping people in, okay?
- [Kyle] Individually?
- Yeah.
- One-on-one.
- Because when
you start lumping,
somebody's feelings get hurt,
it can get confusing.
Let me tell you
what losing players do.
If they're both
sitting there, I'd be like,
oh, it's Adam who screwed
up, he's just bringing me
here to make it more palpable,
like, you've got to do
that one-on-one, okay?
And you really, listen man,
you really have to go there.
- Mhmmm, and
start the conversation
by framing it up as,
I want to talk to you
to get feedback, and
right then and there,
that's gonna set the tone.
This isn't like a friendly,
normal conversation,
this is about
getting that feedback,
having that tough
conversation that you need.
- And just say,
listen, I love you, but.
- Yeah.
- Make this a but conversation.
Be like, listen,
we're homies for life.
But, you know, you're
lazy as fuck, asshole.
- [Kyle] No, yeah, I, honestly,
everything you're
telling me I feel like
I already know,
I just haven't had the,--
- I know you know,
you don't have the balls
to do it yet,
because most people don't,
and the reason I'm not
letting you get off the phone,
is usually people
need this kind of pep talk,
and I'm worried that I haven't
put enough energy into you,
and that in the next four
hours it's gonna go away,
and then you're
gonna shit the bed.
So the reason I'm
keeping you on the phone,
is I'm trying to
give you the audacity
to actually get this done.
Because the
first time you do it,
remember how scared
you were to kiss a girl?
- [Kyle] Oh yeah.
- Remember how after you did it,
you weren't scared anymore?
- [Kyle] Yeah, immediately.
- You need to go have
this negative,--
- No reason.
- you need to have, you need to
go have this
negative conversation.
It will change the
course of your career.
- [Kyle] I appreciate it,
I really do.
I mean, I'm actually
opening up the Austin market
in about a week, so
I gotta do this now,
and that's why I gave you,
I asked the question,
and I've literally
been sitting in
Walmart just hoping
that you guys would call me, so.
- Andy K saved your
day in Walmart, I love it.
Love you bro.
- [Kyle] Alright man,
appreciate it.
- You got it.
- Take care.
- It's cool.
Call-in's fun, right?
- Yeah, that's great.
- We're like
Mike and the Mad Dog.
Who are you?
You're more Mike?
Am I Mad Dog?
- Yeah, definitely.
- All right, fine.
- I think amongst the two of
us, you definitely are Mad Dog.
(Gary and Adam laugh)
- Mike!
So, that was interesting.
- That was great.
I mean, the whole
thing shifted for me
when he said he was 22.
- Yeah, and I
could tell, the voice,
I was like, "He's young."
- [C.J.] Hello?
- Yo, it's GaryVee,
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show,
with Adam Braun,
what's your name?
- [C.J.] You gotta
be kidding me, man.
- Not joking.
(C.J. laughs)
- [C.J.] Yo, my
name is C.J. Reynolds,
I teach in West Philadelphia.
- Born and raised?
- [C.J.] You know,
on the playground's
where I spend most of my days.
(Gary laughs)
- I love it, C.J., how are you?
- [C.J.] I'm doing great, man.
I'm sitting here
watching your feed
and I'm waiting for the
next question to be done,
so I could know if
you were gonna call.
- Well guess what, you won.
- [C.J.] My kids
are coming in the room
to ask me something real quick,
give me ten seconds,
I'll be right with ya.
- Ten, nine, eight--
- [C.J.] So here's my question.
- Okay, oh us.
- [C.J.] I have students that
I teach in West Philadelphia,
I teach at a all boys school.
And we're talking, like,
inner city Philadelphia
and, you know, I'm
gonna show them this feed,
and what I would
love to show them,
is you giving them some advice
as to what to do
after high school,
if the don't
want to go to college.
Because coming
from me, it's like--
- Yeah, you're the teacher.
- [C.J.] The same
thing over and over again.
- Yeah.
- [C.J.] I'm a teacher,
I teach ninth grade literature.
I actually, I hit you
up on Twitter a while ago,
when you were looking for--
- Oh, schools to come,
I actually, yep, yep.
Do we have one, right?
Go ahead, okay.
- [C.J.] So what could
you speak to my students
to kinda give them something to,
you know, they're not
just hearing me but they're,
they know who you are, we
watch your videos in class.
They keep asking
me, they're like...
So, I'm always giving
them your information,
and telling them what
I think you would say,
but I would love for you
to speak to them
directly if you could.
- I could.
Now, like, help
me a little bit here,
because the truth is,
let's start from the top,
and I'm talking to the class
now, and you can clip this.
We'll even send you a clip,
got it Tyler?
We'll send you this clip.
First of all,
how many are there?
- [C.J.] I have,
this graduating class
is about a hundred students.
- Right, so for the hundred
of you, you're all different.
Like, if you don't
want to go to college,
if you want to
figure out what to do,
all of you are different.
Some of you can sing,
some of you are math based,
and you can be analytical.
There's a million
things you could do.
Obviously it's crazy
we got you on this show,
because of MissionU, so
you gotta go check that out.
There's a million
things that I could tell you.
Here's the one
thing I can promise you,
you need to work
your fucking face off.
And, nobody gives a
shit about where you grew up.
Like, nobody's gonna feel sorry
for you, circumstantially,
or feel positive for you.
Like, whether
you're born in the ghetto,
or you're born to a trust fund,
at the end of the day,
once you hit the
real world, nobody cares.
'Cause then the clock's on.
If you're a trust fund baby,
people are judging you,
like, you suck, it's
all 'cause of your daddy.
If you're fucking
from the ghetto,
it's like, you have no shot,
you don't look the part.
Either way, nobody cares.
The end, the only thing that
you should be figuring out
is what are you good at,
and so you should
try a lot of shit, right?
And then you need
to work every minute.
If you're not
gonna go to college,
you're gonna
have to work, right?
Like, if you're not gonna
use the brand of the degree,
and before MissionU means
something to the whole world,
you're gonna have
to work, and prove it.
And nobody's gonna feel bad
that you're working two jobs,
or that you don't have
time to hang out anymore.
C.J., you know this.
Look, these kids, they're young.
We've all been young.
The biggest thing
that's going on is,
it's all the same
advice over and over.
You have to
work your brains out,
and you have to realize,
nobody cares about you.
And once you go into that
place, and you're super solo,
then you have a prayer.
But for any second
that you think
somebody's gonna save you,
Bernie Sanders,
Donald Trump, the government,
your sister, the people
that feel bad for you.
Like, nobody gives a fuck.
Do they understand that C.J.?
I'm askin' you, I'm asking you.
- [C.J.] You know,
so I hear ya, and so that's...
Unfortunately, I think
that that only comes,
that understanding
comes with doing, right?
- It's the
Mike Tyson thing, right?
As soon as you get
actually punched in the mouth,
then you're like, "Oh..."
- [C.J.] Exactly,
and so a lot of my guys
have been literally
punched in the mouth
many times in their lives.
And so it's about,
like, helping them to see
that there's kinda more to
themselves, or that there's,
they have more to offer than...
You know, they've kinda
been beaten down already,
and some guys seem a little bit,
you know, like they have
been to injured to move on--
- Is what, it's just,
do they have the
chip on their shoulder
that somebody owes them
something because
it was fucked up,
or do they have no self esteem
because everybody
told them they can't win?
- [C.J.] Both.
You know, it's a both thing--
- That's exactly right.
- [C.J.] We're
talking about boys.
So, it's a all boys school,
where, you know, 90% of my
guys don't have a dad at home,
which literally, it
makes my job easier,
because, you know, you're a
guy that shows up every day
and tells kids that you love
them, and that you see them,
and that they're not invisible.
But it's me doing that
with my crew at school,
over and over and over again,
and so for like the, you know,
Akil Dandlers, and
the Elijah Goodwins,
and the, you
know, Mark Slawders...
And I'm shouting them
out so they're gonna go,
"Oh shit, Reynolds, you just
said my name on the internet."
- Hey Reynolds, can
I ask you a question?
If I paid for the bus, like,
I know schools are fucked up,
so they can't take advantage,
but if I paid for the bus,
can you bring like
eight or nine of 'em up here
and hang with me for an hour?
- [Reynolds] I'll go.
I will be up
there this afternoon
if you pay for the bus.
That's what I'm gonna do.
- Cool.
So cool.
Send an email to
Gary@VaynerMedia.
I'm gonna pay for the bus.
You're gonna come up here.
We're gonna film it, 'cause
then I'll get into real deep.
I don't want to be the
guy who's just shouting
to 100 people without context.
Let's take
eight or nine of them.
Do some fucking contest.
- [Reynolds] Let's do it.
- Reynolds, do
whatever the fuck you gotta do
to pick eight or nine of them.
Bring them up here,
we'll jam with them,
we'll film that,
and then you can use it
because they look
the part of the other
90 and the 100 next year,
and the 100 next year.
And I knew the answer to
my question was both, right?
Here's the problem.
And this is for everybody,
this is not
just inner city kids.
It's for everybody.
Johnny Texas, you know,
Rick Oklahoma,
and Pam Peru.
The bottom line is it's one
of the two opposite things.
Either you have a
chip on your shoulder
and you think the world
fucked you and you're unlucky.
Or you've
actually been suppressed
and told you can't, right?
In a different way than that.
- [C.J.] Yep, yep.
- It's not the
circumstance, it's the verbiage.
You actually have parents,
they just suck.
Right? They're in pain,
so they don't
want you to succeed.
Misery loves company.
It all ends up in
the same place, Reynolds.
Which is...
It doesn't matter!
And that's what I want
these kids to understand.
It just doesn't matter.
Because once you
get on the field,
it's just the field.
And so the quicker you
can make that mind shift...
And then the other
thing that none of us realize
is how much time you have.
- Yeah.
- Like if I knew I as
an 18-year-old...
I did and that's why I won,
but I didn't even
know to the extreme.
The biggest thing I'm gonna do
with those eight or
nine kids, Reynolds,
is I'm gonna
make them understand
they just have to
put their head down
for 15 years.
And think about, when you're 18,
what 15 years sounds like.
- Yeah.
- Right? It took forever.
- [C.J.] No, it's nothin'.
- Well, it's nothing
to us as we get older.
When you're 18?
Dude, I'll be honest with you,
15 years feels
even a little bit long
to me right now and I'm 41.
When you're 18, 15 years
is your whole fuckin' life.
When you tell them,
eat shit for 15 years,
you'll be 33, a child,
and you can then go win?
That fucks with you,
if I can break through
and get them to understand.
- The only other thing,
this is Adam.
The only other
thing I'll add in,
and I think, one,
it's amazing that Gary's
gonna bring these kids up here,
and I will
absolutely be watching
that session that
you have with them,
but the thing that I've seen,
and this is the one
thing that as a teacher
I think you can
most instill in kids,
is that you
become your expectations.
And people find
their expectations,
sometimes externally,
sometimes internally,
sometimes it's a
parent or a coach
or a teacher or a mentor,
that helps you understand
your self-expectation.
Other people are just
intrinsically born
with this belief
that they're gonna
go do something great,
but you become
your expectations,
and so every one of those kids,
regardless of
their situation today,
if they can
redefine the expectation
for their future,
then that creates
the underlying motivation
to bust ass for
the next 15 years,
but if they don't
have the expectation
of the outcome in the future,
and they don't hold
themselves accountable to it,
then they won't
get to that place.
- If they understood The Man
that's holding them down
is in their fucking dome,
everything would change.
- [C.J.] True, yes.
I love it.
So hey, listen, can I
shout one thing out real quick?
- Yep.
- [C.J.] If people
want to check out my guide,
I have a YouTube site called
- Do it, go.
- [C.J.] Real Rap
with The Reynolds.
I post teacher videos,
like how people that
teach in the inner city
should stop going
there for two years
to, like, do their
good deed and then move on,
but they should,
like, go there and stay,
and this is how you can stay
and like, how you can just
keep crushing it every year,
year after year,
no matter what the
kids bring in with them,
that you're, like,
helping them and loving them.
- What's the name of
the video series again?
- What's the name again?
- [C.J.] It's called
Real Rap with The Reynolds.
- Real Rap with The Reynolds.
Good, we'll put it there.
(bell dings)
Reynolds, I can't
wait to fuckin' see you.
You better get
your ass here soon.
The season's almost over.
I'll see you soon.
I'll see you next week.
Let's figure it out.
See ya.
I think that's a good one.
Nah, I think that's good.
That was fuckin' awesome.
- That was great.
- He hit on all the
right things, right,
the cliche, like,
I'm a good person,
two years kind of thing.
Adam, how do you want
to close this out here?
And then you get to ask
the question of the day.
- I get to ask the question.
- Mhmmm.
- To you? Or to?
- No, to the world.
A.K.A., a
couple thousand people.
- Yeah.
I want to hear
what your hope is for your
children's higher education.
- I'll answer mine real quick
and then you guys
can all answer yours.
I know a lot of you are young
and far away from children,
many others have children,
and I'd love to see answers.
Mine is very simple, which is,
I just want my kids to be happy.
First of all, I'm
unique because I made it
without higher education,
so I have no
expectations or wants or needs.
I want them to do
what they want to do,
A.K.A., in reverse, too.
If Xander wants to be the
greatest scholar of all time,
with no practical execution,
the thing that I
would make fun of,
that I want him to
be the greatest fuckin'
pontificator and theorist ever,
as long as that is
what he wants to be about.
So, from my standpoint,
that's what I want out of it.
I also recognize
they're seven and four,
11, 14 years from today,
with things like
what you're up to,
the way technology's working,
and the way the
ecosystem's playing out,
this is why I'm so upset
for all the parents I have
on the Upper East
Side of Town School
and all these things,
is they don't realize,
Horseman and Avenues,
they don't realize the buzzsaw
that they're walking into.
They think their
kids need to go to chess,
and they need to be
six-year-olds that are prepping
for S.A.T.s, and I'm like,
what the fuck world do you think
little fucking Johnny,
excuse me, not Johnny,
little fucking Hudson
is gonna be living in?
Anyway, that's my answer.
- I like it.
- I love you, brother.
- I love you too, man.
- Adam Braun.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)